[Musique]
je suis pas qu'elle devienne pas
québécois je suis cogné au code point
final ok je suis chez moi sur mon terres
ancestrales
ce n'est pas la france c'est pas
l'angleterre s'est cogné hockey près
d'un an après la légalisation du
cannabis et nation mohawk de kanesatake
akwesasne kanawa qui souhaitent
participer à cette nouvelle strict à
mérode sont généralement pas les
bienvenus dans ces petits commerces et
les propriétaires ont accepté nous
ouvrir leurs portes
on s'est donc rendu dans les trois
communautés pour voir comment ils
comprendre leur part du gâteau
en arrivant à cannes et s'attaquer c'est
impossible de manquer toutes les
boutiques de cannabis
il y en a environ une vingtaine qui sont
très bien afficher sur bada deuil et 10
heures du matin et le stationnement est
déjà plein environ une quinzaine de
voitures est que ça continue à arriver
comme ça sans arrêt dans les boutiques
de canisses attaque et on ne se prive
pas de vendre des produits prohibés
les bonbons des boissons gazeuses du
haschich chocolat on trouve même une
machine distributrice et les fleurs de
cannabis sont vendues en vrac
elles ne proviennent pas de producteur
autorisés par santé canada
mais plutôt de fournisseurs situés
principalement dans l'ouest canadien
elle est disponible ici
mais les blessures mineures
il ya quelques mois sa boutique se
trouvait dans un simple conteneurs
aujourd'hui son local est trop petit
pour accueillir tous les clients dont la
majorité vient d'extérieur de la
communauté ce planning 6 pence et essar
oui on y arrive vite à great falls
oui au québec il est interdit de faire
la promotion du cannabis mais mes
racines box ne se prive pas pour
afficher ses produits sur les réseaux
sociaux
la boutique a même pu compter sur
l'appui du rappeur snoop dogg lors de
son passage à montréal en mai dernier
devant âgées afin de protéger la
pérennité de la municipalité d'oka
depuis quelques semaines la tension est
vive entre la communauté de cannes et
s'attaquer et la municipalité d'oka
à l'origine ce conflit la décision d'un
promoteur immobilier de céder au conseil
mohawk une pinède de 60 hectares le même
territoire disputé pendant la crise
d'oka en 1990 les propriétaires de
boutiques de cannabis viennent
aujourd'hui s'immiscer dans une
situation déjà complexe
elles se multiplient malgré un moratoire
décrété en 2009 par le conseil de bande
le grand chef serge dotti simon aimerait
les voir disparaître si le maire d'oka
pascal quévillon souhaite que la
gendarmerie royale du canada intervienne
il ya plus de cabanas potes
chacun s'est acquis que le stud et c'est
partout à travers le québec
je suis convaincu que le cannabis qui
est vendu ici une bonne partie des vient
pas des choses légales alors encore
qu'est ce qu'on fait avec ça
au canada les communautés autochtones
sont compétence fédérale
mais la distribution du cannabis et la
responsabilité des provinces
au québec la loi encadrant cannabis
prévoit que le gouvernement peut
conclure des ententes avec les premières
nations
mais le ministère de la santé et des
services sociaux nous indique qu'aucun
accord n'a été conclu à ce jour
presto najwa qui était né crise a ouvert
une première boutique le 20 avril 2018
plus de six mois avant la légalisation
et pour lui pas question de négocier
avec québec
je suis libre je suis là dans mon coeur
plus fait les choses que j'ai besoin de
faire pour vivre je fais un mal à
personne le mois qui se considère comme
un traditionaliste
il ne reconnaît donc pas la légitimité
du conseil de bande
le système qui est clé pour nous enlever
nos doigts pour enlever nos nos vies
j'ai vraiment institutions coloniales
depuis les violents événements de
janvier 2004 au cours desquels la maison
de l'ancien grand chef james gabriel a
été incendié aucune police autochtone
patrouille la communauté les policiers
de la sûreté du québec sont responsables
la sécurité à cannes et s'attaquer mais
manifestement elle n'ose pas fermé la
vingtaine de boutiques de cannabis le
grand chef souhaite aujourd'hui un
retour des peacekeepers mois pour faire
respecter la loi et fermer ces commerces
qu'ils considèrent illégaux comment tu
réagirais aussi à une force policière
qui venait de voir qu'ils disaient de
plus le droit de vendre ça arriverait
jamais parce que les gens d'ici vont pas
prendre soin les autres qui vont pousser
pour pour l'avoir le cannabis légal
opposants se laisser un grand des
polices qui faisait une créature
l'acquérir pour fermer en prison les
gens comme moi les objets qui faisait le
cannabis ben ils vont enfin ces ip
[Musique]
le classique à bing
pour visiter et mme sarr les qataris
[Musique]
après avoir été chef de police dans la
communauté pendant dix ans lewis medjo
et maintenant le propriétaire du premier
et seul producteur autorisé de cannabis
autochtones au canada savane leaf est
situé à coup ça ce n'est une communauté
mohawk à cheval entre le québec
l'ontario et l'état de new york
ce match on croit que le gouvernement
n'a pas suffisamment consultés les
premières nations pour mettre en oeuvre
son projet de légalisation le toutefois
décidé de suivre les règles du fédéral
il a demandé un permis en bonne et due
forme
aujourd'hui ils embauchent une
cinquantaine de moat d'accusation mais
sa certification santé canada ne lui
permet pas de vendre ces plantes à sa
propre communauté
non
au canada une taxe d'assise est exigée
aux producteurs de cannabis 75% ce
montant est remis aux provinces le oui
ce match elle aimerait que cet argent
revienne à sa communauté et voudrait me
prouve à l'instar de canisses attaqué
deux points de vente de cannabis ont
pignon sur rue à cruz azul et ses
commerces récalcitrants ne reconnaissent
pas l'autorité du conseil de bande qui a
imposé un moratoire sur la vente de
cannabis
ici aussi ses boutiques sont source de
tension
en février dernier après la fermeture
d'un de ces établissements
un véhicule de police a été incendié
[Musique]
depuis le 6 ou le conseil de bande à
coup et ça ce n'est à lancer un
processus d'accréditation pour obtenir
des permis de vente et de production de
cannabis
le propriétaire de green chip nature à
tenter sa chance et est aujourd'hui fin
prêt pour se lancer en affaires
[Musique]
c'est à kahnawake le conseil de bande a
décidé d'être prudent donc il ya un
moratoire sur la vente et la production
cannabis même si 55% de la population
qui a voté pour lors d'un référendum
on veut éviter la prolifération de
boutiques de cannabis comme c'est le cas
avec le tabac dans la communauté
malgré ça il ya un dispensaire qui over
au courant des derniers mois mais était
fermé cinq fois par les peacekeepers la
police locale
dufour date de s'attaquer kahnawake et a
causé ce n'est les mois qui sont
unanimes le gouvernement fédéral ne les
a pas suffisamment consultés avant de
légaliser le cannabis mais aujourd'hui
ils veulent tous profiter de cette
nouvelle manne
[Musique]